Avatar Zoo plunges moviegoers back into
the beautifully realized world of
Pandora but did James Cameron forget to
flesh out the film's heroine natiri we
hardly know you in terms of his visuals
2009's Avatar remains in a class of its
own it revolutionized 3D in Hollywood
for several years to the point where you
practically couldn't see any movie in a
theater without it getting a rushed 3D
treatment when it comes to criticizing
Avatar most people take issue with the
story itself drawing comparisons to
fungally the last rainforest and
Pocahontas Avatar is a typical white
savior story of a marine Jake Sully
who's given a new body via an avatar he
then assimilates into Navi culture and
while he was initially on the side of
humanity he soon switches over to the
indigenous Navi realizing they shouldn't
have their way of life appended due to
colonization and who helps him along
that Journey but is soon to be wife
nathiri natiri may be a secondary
protagonist but in Avatar she has a word
worthwhile arkle her own she brings Jake
into her tribe but turns her back on him
when she realizes he was acting as a spy
the whole time after he proves his
intentions are pure she comes back
around and falls in love with him all
over again a character rock is one of
acceptance and willingness to trust it's
just a shame she hasn't given more to do
in the latest installments of the
franchise Avatar the way of water naturi
is a fierce Warrior without much is
evident from the film's opening
sequences whether hunting for food for a
family or taking down a supply chain
from the sky people naturally has a
skill and bravery to get the job done
it's just a shame we never really get a
chance to see her put her skills in
action more in the way of water after
Jake and they tiri's children are put In
Harm's Way with a resurrected Avatar
body of Colonel quarrych Jake realizes
that he can't endanger his loved ones
over this war as a result they decide to
move away to be with another clan while
someone else takes Jake's Place Made
series against it but eventually she
relents and agrees to go for for the
betterment of her family I need you
with me from that point forward niteri
remains stagnant she loves her family
and as clear as she would do anything to
keep them safe she also wants to be a
warrior but there's too much story going
on for everyone else where it feels like
natiri gets pushed to the side to do
anything interesting with either of
those ideas in the way of water natiri
pretty much exists to react to her kids
in Peril forfeiting any potential for
growth and instead being relegated to a
series of reactions this is our home one
reason why it feels Nate Siri is so
thinly written could probably be
attributed to there being an abundance
of characters for the way of water to
focus on in addition to bringing back
Jake and they Theory they now have four
children to care for this is in addition
to spider who has a tendency to follow
the family around him whatever they do
and that's not even getting into the new
members of the mechaina clan there's
simply too much going on and other new
characters get a chance at the Limelight
forcing naturally into the Shadows it's
a shame because there's something
potentially interesting about Natori
wanting to juggle her desire to be a
warrior or protecting her family based
on recent reports James Cameron has an
entire script of Jake and natiri's time
as Warriors which at least sounds like
something that would give nadesiri the
development she so desperately deserves
but the movie we got completely
Sidelines her to the point we don't even
see her for vast stretches of time by
the end of the film we know just as much
about Natori as at the beginning of the
film she loves her family and she'll
kill to protect them but there's no
forward growth then again if camera
manages to get up to Avatar 7 there will
be ample opportunities to give nades
here either character Arc she deserves